but fast yesterday I joined Jeremy
Corbyn on the campaign trail in
Yorkshire and we began by talking of
course about that terror attack I'd like
to get your response to what we've seen
with the attacks at London Bridge
watched the lessons that we should be
learning from it total shock at what
happened
total shock that somebody would kill
people at a conference that was dealing
with rehabilitation of prisoners and
prevent strategy and then to go outside
and threaten people with a knife and
then the police had to do what they have
to do and we now end up with three
people dead two of whom were trying to
help people get through horrible times
in their lives and so I do think there
are lessons that we have to learn from
this and there has to be a very full
investigation into the circumstances of
the prison sentence that was served and
a release from it and what services can
do to help on that note and it's been
calm the attacker was given an
indeterminate jail sentence wasn't he
and for being convicted of a plot to
blow up the London Stock Exchange
overturned on appeal he was then
released after spending eight years in
jail
of course his original sentence was 16
years do you think that people convicted
of terrorism offences need to serve a
full prison sentence I think it depends
on the circumstances depends on the
sentence but crucially depends on what
they've done in there not necessarily no
not necessarily no I think there has to
be an examination of how our prison
services work and crucially what happens
to someone released from prison because
I need to know whether or not the parole
board were involved in his release
apparently they were not they made that
statement quite quickly after the
release after after yesterday's terrible
incident secondly that there were
apparently no probation service
involvement in monitoring this form of
prisoner who after all had only served
half his sentence and he came out I
think a year ago and there has to be an
examination of what goes on in the
prison because
prisons ought to be a place where people
have put away because of major serious
offenses but also a place where
rehabilitation takes place due to change
well we do things one properly fund our
prison service so that the prison
officers are able to do their job both
being prison officers as well as
educators as well as people that deal
with dangerous prisoners who've
committed very dangerous very serious
offenses secondly that to be a
psychological assessment of somebody in
his situation before they are released
to see if they are actually a danger and
ever-present danger to society and the
parole board be involved in making that
decision whether they go out ahead of
full sentence and after that we have a
probation service worthy of the name our
privation service was half privatized is
not up to scratch is not able to deal
with the number of cases they have to
deal with and a lot of prisoners are
simply put on a tag or ex-prisoners
rather put on a tag which if they breach
clearly then that the police are alerted
now in the case of this individual he
obviously was not in breach of the tag
because he was at a conference which it
was a wholly legitimate place to be and
but something happened and he killed
people at the conference and then
himself was killed on the street but
actually say he was killed on the street
the police shot him dead were they right
to shoot him dead I think they had no
choice they were stuck with a situation
where there was a credible threat of a
bomb belt around his body and it's an
awful situation for any police officer
any public servant to be put in and
you've spoken about sheep's kill before
and in 2015 you said I'm not happy with
the shoot-to-kill policy in general I
think it's quite dangerous I think it
could also be counterproductive is that
story of you this was a situation where
the police were faced with a very
dangerous position somebody had already
killed two people then the police may or
may not have known that at that point
and he was wrestled to the ground and
as far as they were concerned he had
explosives strapped to his body and they
took the action that they could I think
the police have to take what action they
can to defend people in that city so
have you changed your mind then when you
said no I'm happy with the points I made
in the past particularly in relation to
Northern Ireland this is going back
quite a long way was that there was a
concern in Northern Ireland that the
police were adopting a shoot-to-kill
policy when it was possible to arrest
people rather than shoot them and that's
my point they should never be the first
alternative to shoot people but if
there's no other alternative then that's
what you do okay and I just want to talk
a little bit more widely about keeping
people safe because this is what lots of
voters will be basing some of that
decision on will this person keep me
safe if their prime minister belated
manifesto says that you want to ensure
the powers exercised by the security
services are proportionate and used in
accordance with human rights some people
read that and think you want to make it
harder for the security services to do
their jobs no I want to protect public
servants be they in the Armed Forces or
security services somewhere else that
they know that they have a code that
they have to adopt which is one about
protecting life and protecting the human
rights of all of us and that they are
also accountable for what they do
hence the all the things in our
manifesto are about parliamentary
accountability of government services
and of security just talking about human
rights in particular do you ever worry
that in the wake of terror attacks for
example the balance between security and
human rights swings too far in favor of
human rights in favor of security as
opposed to human rights well the two
things don't have to be indivisible by
any means well difficult decisions have
to be made all the time that's what
government has to do and that's what
public life is about but the fundamental
has to be the rights of the individual
to express their views and society in a
in a proportionate way and it has to be
about our rights of free speech and
assembly that is surely what what we're
about as a country that's why we are
part of the UN Human Rights system it's
why we've
part of the European Convention on Human
Rights these things are actually quite
important because they protect all of us
do you think that sometimes human rights
are under threat though when it comes
when it comes to and the balance between
them and security you have to create a
secure society and you have to defend
human rights at the same time if you
give up all your democratic and human
rights then you've actually given in to
those that were taken away anyway I'm
talking about that issue of human rights
and you've said previously that and
Shamima begum the Islamic state bride
should be allowed to return to the
United Kingdom are you still concerned
about the idea of stripping and British
people from their citizenship if they do
go to fight that you had as cause as a
board yes because if you strip away
their citizenship where are they going
to go they then are going to become
stateless people roaming around into
uncovered places like in Libya like in
parts of Syria and they create another
terrorist force of tomorrow Isis or
something else surely if somebody is a
citizen of any one country then it's up
to that country to take responsibility
for them and that's why we said that she
should be brought back to Britain for
questioning possible charge but
certainly for questioning as a way of
gaining intelligence on what motivated
her in the first place and what her
rights actually are I mean there's a
point here that if you if you take away
the rights of people and send them into
that dangerous place then actually the
ultimately we're all in greater danger
but some would listen to you and say you
know you don't say you're not saying
that terrorists should have to serve the
full four sentences and you're not
saying that you're going to give
increased powers to the security
services you're not saying that you're
going to make it more difficult for
jihadists to return to the United
Kingdom is this man going to keep you
safe if he's permanent how does that
return are going to return to have to
face questioning if we let them loose
into a none government space like Libya
we're all in greater danger in the long
run it is making us safer by preventing
the growth of terrorist forces by
preventing the growth of irrational
powerful forces and also looking at
who's funding them looking who's making
money out of them look who's look who's
supporting them those are issues are
very important but also having a
inclusive approach in our society to
stop people being radicalized and ending
up in that very dangerous place which is
a threat to all of us
now their NATO summit is taking place
this week the kind of summit that if you
become Prime Minister you're going to be
hosting and what countries would you
consider to be our allies
well many countries are our hellos all
around the world I mean any country that
signs up to the generality of the
democratic way of life of human rights
of Jeremy Corbyn was Prime Minister what
all of our neighbors are obviously
important allies the European countries
are important allies the United States
and Ally but let's look at it on the
basis of how we approach the real
threats this world which are probably
climate change and issues like that and
I would look forward to meeting
President Trump to have a chat with him
about his designs on our health service
DG ally
well I haven't had the pleasure of
meeting President Trump so I'd be happy
to have a discussion with him but what I
would simply say is this that a
relationship with the United States in
the future will be a trade relationship
yes but we're not going to give up our
public services to the United States and
I think what the Prime Minister's doing
in allowing these trade talks to go on
now for more than two years which are a
threat to so much of our way of life in
so much of our way of life in terms of
our security of conditions in health and
our security ambitions in environment
and food and handing over our public
services to American companies to come
in and run them I mean they would
dispute a lot of what you're saying that
they would say that actually the NHS is
not on the table when it comes to it
it's absolutely on the table it's quite
clearly there in the document which has
been sent away for text drawing up talk
about NATO and because NATO is something
that you've previously and talks about a
new new cruise an MP as well in 2011 you
said we have got to be realistic that
NATO is a major problem and a major
difficulty and we have to campaign
against NATO's power its influence and
its global reach because it's a danger
to world peace and a danger to security
if your Prime Minister is that the
message you'd be taking to NATO summits
what are we
take the NATO summit is this that we
NATO was founded as a result of the
second world war it was a product two
strengths of the Cold War and I think we
have to use all of the countries of NATO
to try and builds if you change your
mind on NATO
no just I can develop my oven slightly
just to say we have to develop security
around the world by bringing about a
respectful relationship with Russia and
other countries but also we have to
recognize the need to bring about peace
where it is in danger such as in Iran or
such as in Korea at the present time and
that can be done by serious diplomatic
negotiations and I'm keen to talk about
and some domestic issues now okay
because if your Prime Minister your
policy on brexit something that lots of
people be very interested in is to
negotiate a new deal put that to a
referendum and then stay neutral in that
referendum is that really showing
leadership to stay neutral yes because
this country's got to come together we
can't be forever negotiating how people
voted and debating how people voted in
2016 will you actually vote in a
referendum
can we come under what the referendum is
going to say first because we will put a
decisions the British people that we
will have negotiated with the EU which
will be a trade relationship which will
be protection the Good Friday Agreement
our rights but it will be outside the EU
will not be members of the EU then we'll
put that alongside remain and so that
way the people could make a decision my
role would be the honest broker of
bringing people together in order to
carry out that decision would you vote
in the referendum yeah yeah would you
tell us at the time how you can about
you have to wait and see so you can't
even tell us how you can about at the
time listen I want to negotiate a deal
with the European Union that does
protect manufacturing industry trade and
jobs and does protect the the trade
relationship that we have we have with
Europe because if we go down the road
that the Prime Minister saying goes to
the sweetheart deal of the United States
there's going to be huge threats to
industrial or do you want to negotiate
it would be outside membership of the EU
what would maintain
would that deal that you want to
negotiate include free movement of
people or would that come to an end I
mean I don't think free movement a
totally would could ever come to an end
because of the relationship of families
between Britain and Europe the needs of
all of our services the fact is for many
people voters in the referendum for an
end a free munich people didn't they I
don't think they voted to have 40,000
vacancies in Britain I don't think they
voted to lose all those European doctors
and I do think we have to recognize the
rights of those many European Union
Nationals that made their homes here and
made a fantastic contribution to our
country and actually helped us run our
health service at the moment all of that
is under threat because of the
uncertainty our whole process will bring
uncertain to an end all the Prime
Minister's offering is actually a
negotiation with the United States which
would take at least seven years to
negotiate it's not all going to be done
and dusted now in a short time under
Boris Johnson I'm keen to talk and a bit
about your manifesto as well
of course because for every just in
particular about the spending pages in
the manifesto because for every pound
the Conservatives want to spend if they
become the party of government labour
would spend 28 pounds I spoke to Karen
Ferber and the head of the CBI and she
said that Labour's policies would crack
the foundations of our economy is that
really a responsible plan for government
I think it is a very responsible way of
looking at the needs of this country all
of disbanding pledges in the labor
manifesto all of what we're proposing
would take us in terms of public
services roughly up to the level of
France and Germany at the moment we're
way below that what it would do is give
us the opportunity to properly fund our
education to have a median incomes pay a
lot more tax on France and Germany as
well don't they so maybe we're not in
fact we would all have to pay more tax
we're not worried we're not raising
taxes for ninety five percent of the
population
what we're doing is raising corporate
taxation income tax you may not be
raising for ninety five percent of their
population but people are knowing comes
will be paying more tax under labour
wouldn't they under things like that
marriage tax allotments
the merge tax allowance will bring about
equality between those it's not true to
say is that 95
way-hey more tax on the labor but that
is 250 pounds for a married couple at
the moment which doesn't give the same
advantage it's not correct tax rise
there are no tax rises for the 95
percent of population but think of the
benefits you get from it you get a
better education services properly
funded you get a government that's
determined to invest in the
infrastructure needs of this country you
get green industrial revolution jobs and
you get a growing economy as a result of
it look we cannot go on as a society it
was more than half a million kids in
oversized classes we cannot go on with
many thousands of people sleeping rough
we cannot go on with these levels of
poverty and inequality exists in Britain
or for the middle aged who thought they
were moving into a period of stability
and strength in their lives suddenly
finding their grossly in debt to pay for
their kids to go through university or
their older older parents to get the
social care they need we can't go on
like this that's why our manifesto is
there to try and deal with these
inequalities and develop an expanding
economy for the future what others would
argue as well is that something else
that we can't go on allegations of
anti-semitism within the Labor Party and
this week the chief rabbis said in his
view you're unfit for high office
because what he describes as a new
poison of racism has taken hold in
labour sanctioned from the very top what
I want to know is why didn't you
apologize for it what why did you Lucy
we've made it very clear as a party we
apologized for and regret any degrees of
anti-semitism anyone like to take up
Chanti - I've made that clear can I just
say this well I became leader of the
Labour Party there were no processes for
dealing with this whatsoever
they've all been introduced since I
became leader and Jenny formed bouquet
general secretary the egregious cases I
introduced as purse personally
introduced a rule change to deal with
this we also introduced an education
system to deal with this within the
party and I just say this you think
you've done anything wrong when it comes
to handling of anti-semitism
I wished our party had acted on it more
rapidly at the very beginning and dealt
with it at that point and also that I
want to make it very clear to the Jewish
community it's a Muslim community
to any other community anyone under
threat because of persecution because of
attacks on their temples mosques
synagogues or places of worship will be
very secure under a Labour government it
will make sure there is full funding of
all the protection measures they need
and full respect for their religion
their faith and their place in our
society the Jewish people suffered like
no other in the 20th century through
anti-semitism in Germany which led to
the horrors of the Holocaust the Jewish
people have made an incredible
contribution to my party to our trade
unions to our life and intellectual life
in this country I value that I and I
thank them for everything they do I want
some communities to be safe so why do
you think it is then if you do value the
Jewish community so much that if you
listen to what they're saying and you
always say leadership is about listening
then they are really worried a recent
poll eighty-seven percent of British
Jews said to consider you to be an
anti-semite this weekend The Sunday
Telegraph publishing a poll eighty-four
percent of people saying he posed a
threat to British Jews I posed no threat
to any community whatsoever in this
country I've spent my life fighting
racism fighting against racist attacks
87% of British you say they think you're
anti-semitic I simply say this there is
no place anywhere for anti-semitism in
our society ever ok a couple of things
just to end the interview with and you
asked recently if you thought the
monarchy was fit for purpose and you
said you think it requires improvement
what improvements do you think you'd
like to say well I think the behavior of
individuals within the royal family is
being looked at shall we say I do think
the question of the size of the family
and all that they do but I do think the
public as a whole would want to see
those kind of changes and the debate
around the behavior of Prince Andrew has
actually brought that to the fore so you
think it's a bit too big effectively
well I think it's there's a lot of
people attached the royal family ok
and then just finally you're an Arsenal
fan who don't the next manager well good
debate personally I like Patrick Vieira
iconic player brilliant guy and has done
so much for education of children back
home in Africa I think Patrick Vieira
okay Jeremy Corbyn thank you very much
another way won't be me what happens at
the election no matter what happens I
will not be no matter what happens in
the election I will not be the Arsenal
manager well that might be good news for
some people whatever but that's the
situation thank you very much thank you